où
[Musique]
à tanger une proposition malhonnête
évidemment à te faire j'ai sex and sing
girls pourrez le regarder ensemble
gentiment gentil tu fais quoi dans la
vie
il est des fans le plus connu c'est la
fin du set et regarde
ça me faire très bien
ta fille
c'est rire toi pour être à magnac un
vola en tuant sérigne à partir de quand
on peut considérer qu'on connaît
vraiment quelqu'un c'est la première
fois depuis longtemps que je me suis tu
attends juste c'est bon je l' ai peur de
ne pas avoir assez
[Musique]
et comment tu as fait un peu bizarre ce
genre de question dans ce contexte nous
tu sais je suis dans une cabane tout un
art c'est une vue privilégiée sur les
hommes je me crois si je te dis que
j'aime mon métier
non je crois a souvent dû plusieurs à 8
des clients j'avais c'est vrai tu es un
client vincent lavenu
[Musique]